this is the fifth day of the impeachment
in Korean to US President Donald Trump
you have just been listening to the
ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sandlin he made an opening
statement and has just been questioned
by Adam Schiff the leader of the House
Intelligence Committee the Democrats and
also the counsel for the Democrats as
well
he made news he said basically there was
a quid pro quo we've heard that phrase
quite a bit he used that exact phrase in
his statement he said it became clear to
him that the only way Ukraine was going
to get about four hundred million
dollars in aid that had already been
proved by both parties the only way to
get that aid was for Ukraine's new
president Solinsky to make an
announcement
not necessarily to an investigation that
make an announcement of an investigation
into Purisima a company that buys former
Vice President Joe Biden's son was on
the board so basically an investigation
into the Biden's he also made clear that
everyone was in the loop another exact
quote everyone was in the loop basically
that meant he said Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo at some point was aware of
this he referenced repeatedly Rudy
Giuliani the president's personal
attorney who was in charge basically of
these efforts Secretary of Energy Rick
Perry as well chief of staff Mick Mick
Mulvaney that is former national
security adviser john bolton kurt volker
who also testified former special envoy
to to ukraine you testified yesterday
and he implied that at some point vice
president mike pence also became aware
so let's go ahead and play just a bit of
the testimony of an ambassador gordon
Soglin let's listen this is not my first
time cooperating with this committee as
you know I've already provided ten hour
of deposition testimony and I did so
despite directives from the White House
and the State Department that I refused
to appear as many others have done I
agreed to testify because I respect the
gravity of the moment and I believe I
have an obligation to account fully for
my role in these events just to let
everyone know things stand right now
this is just a quick five minute break
before the Republicans get a chance to
to question the Ambassador Kimberly how
could is following the developments
outside of the White House we're gonna
speak to Kimberly in just a moment first
was good Heidi Joe Castro who's just
outside the chambers where this hearing
is being held or they're on a quick
five-minute recess it's been quite a
quite a morning there in Washington I D
that's right it's been quite a morning
with Gordon Salman starting his
testimony by saying yes there was
absolutely an explicit quid pro quo
referencing that there was a White House
meeting dangled for president szalinski
an invitation for him to meet with Trump
and he and Salman said that it was very
clear that the president was not going
to allow szalinski to visit without
launching investigations without Ukraine
announcing there wasn't launching
investigations into Joe Biden but then
it gets even more interesting when
someone goes further and talks about the
second quid pro quo that has been
alleged here that being that Trump also
was withholding the military aid to
Ukraine in exchange for the public
announcement of those investigations and
someone has very carefully worded
testimony here I know you read some of
his exact quotes out loud but others
that struck me was Salman said it was
quote common knowledge that these two
things were linked that the aid and the
statement for the investigations into
the Biden's were conditioned and he said
that it was absolutely conditioned and
this is how he explained his reasoning
leading him to that conclusion
I was adamantly suppo adamantly opposed
to any suspension of aid as the
Ukrainians needed those funds to fight
against Russian aggression
I tried diligently to ask why the aid
was suspended but I never received a
clear answer still haven't to this day
in the absence of any credible
explanation for the suspension of aid I
later came to believe that the
resumption of security aid would not
occur until there was a public statement
from Ukraine committing to the
investigations of the 2016 elections and
burry smih as mr. Giuliani had demanded
you can really tell how he's trying to
thread the needle there Rochelle because
he also under questioning said something
that appears to be supportive of the
president another quote I never heard
from President Trump that aid was
conditioned on an announcement of the
investigations referencing at that point
the phone conversations that sunland had
with President Trump he was asked
specifically about a conversation in
early September which occurred right
after it was brought to his attention
that there was alarm among the other US
ambassadors saying that that was crazy
that it appeared that this aid was
linked to the political investigations
well someone testified that he called
Trump in the middle of the night then
got a very sour Trump who was in a bad
mood and when Salman asked Trump what is
it that you do want he said that the
president's words were I want nothing I
do not want two quid pro quo but
szalinski the president of Ukraine
should quote do the right thing so he
sunland is saying that that affirmed
what his analysis of the situation was
already at that point that the security
aid and that the investigations into the
Biden's were tied so heidi this is a lot
of what someone is saying
it is new information you could you
could maybe depending on how you
describe it you can say he's updating
his testimony changing it but as she
said a lot of us is contradictory to the
10 hours of deposition that he already
gave he tried to say or insinuate that
some of that is because he wasn't able
to get his documents from the State
Department because they won't allow him
to can you talk a little bit more about
that because that's something that added
Adam Schiff referenced as well that none
of the documents that the committee has
requested has the White House turned
over that's right it's interesting
because someone has been sort of all
over the place on his testimonies
reversing himself in the past but today
we heard him lay the blame also at the
feet of the US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo saying that the State Department
has not allowed him to access records of
his conversations other documents that
Sandlin says he needs to refresh his
apparently not great memory and further
drying Pompeo into the mix Solon
testified that he got messages from
Pompeo throughout his dealings with
Ukraine encouraging him saying that he
was doing a great job and that she
should keep at it it's interesting too
it's it's interesting to think what the
motivation here is for sunland is he
trying to shift some of this
responsibility toward his superiors in
order to dig himself out of the legal
pit that he might find himself in it's
interesting he notably doesn't take the
blame for any of what he's saying happen
he blames Rudy Giuliani the private
attorney a president Trump for what
someone says has been this insidious
campaign trying to get more trying to
get those investigations out of Ukraine
and putting more and more as leverage
from the US first the White House
meeting for szalinski and later the
security aid destined for Ukraine and
then he blames Pompeo for apparently not
telling Sandlin that he was doing
anything wrong for rather encouraging
him
as sahlan was having these meetings with
ukrainian officials and making those
explicit demands saying if you don't
give up those the public announcement of
the investigations you will not be
getting the security aid from the US the
bigger question is how much how much
blame does he put at the feet of
President Trump and notably he seems to
be the most tight-lipped when he's asked
that question Michelle okay Heidi he was
posted there from Capitol Hill let's go
now to the White House our White House
correspondent Kimberly halket Kimberly
the key words from ambassador Solomon I
followed the directions of the president
talking about the man in the house right
behind you
that seems to be the beginning and end
of all of this what do we know about
what the White House is watching is
paying attention to well the US
president is expected to leave the White
House momentarily he's trying to shift
directions away from the headlines in
Capitol Hill to Austin Texas where he's
headed to touts a creation of jobs at an
apple plant that he says is a direct
benefit as a result of his policies but
there's no question that what most
people are going to be focusing on is
this testimony that has just taken place
on Capitol Hill and I should note in the
last few minutes as you were talking
with our correspondent hi Joe Castro the
chair of the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff spoke to reporters
very briefly I did manage to catch a
feed of some of that coming from Capitol
Hill and he said that essentially this
testimony speaks to the heart of the
issue of bribery high crimes and
misdemeanors there's no question that
the sort of the allegations that have
been put forward by Gordon Sandland the
ambassador to the European Union really
has implicated not just the u.s.
president but also the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo and the vice president
of the United States Mike Pence and as a
result Adam Schiff going on to say just
moments ago that there's no question
that this is why they do not want these
documents public that they have been
attempting to obstruct this
investigation because of their
first-hand knowledge of the scheme so
given those statements it's pretty
unusual that the
House Intelligence chair was speaking in
the midst of proceedings to reporters
they seem to believe judging from that
language that this is a pivotal moment
as we're on day four of these public
hearings so now we're watching very
carefully to see what the President of
the United States is going to say it's
notable that he is leaving his departure
to later in the day perhaps watching
these proceedings we do know that he
watched them yesterday and before the in
advance of ambassador sonless testimony
the president said on a tweet saying
that there was a lot of confidence
coming from the White House in fact
during these proceedings the press
secretary Stephanie Grisham also sent
out a text saying there is a stark
difference between truth and opinion
truth derived sustenance and sustenance
from facts where his opinion is a
judgment influenced by president
prejudices apologies she goes on with
the hashtag impeachment circus so the
the Republicans defenders of the
president seemed to be trying to make
the case that this is a circus that this
is statement not backed up by fact it's
going to be very very hard to do that
moving forward given the testimony that
we've just heard from the ambassador to
the European Union and given the fact
that so much of the testimony from
various people Kimberly
it matches up it lines up and it seems
that the White House in the past has
tried to has questioned a lot of things
question the loyalty of Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh has tried to paint
people as never Trump errs ambassador
Gordon Psalm one does doesn't fit I
never never Trump her tell us a little
bit more about him well the fact of the
matter is is that he's a major
Republican donor so that makes it pretty
challenging given the fact that
essentially he's one of the president's
own so the fact that he is saying all of
this makes it that much more difficult
now for Republicans to defend we heard
in the opening statement from Devin
Nunez where he essentially tried to
characterize this even using some of the
language that we've heard from Democrats
alleging them that they had a sort of
debunk conspiracy theory with regard to
quid pro quo well the problem is is that
it's not a conspiracy theory if
Gordan sunland's actually testifying
that that's exactly what it was quid pro
quo so it's going to make that defense
very difficult and given the fact that
now this sir has also been testimony
that there was knowledge of the scheme
that extended far and wide sort of to
the outer corners of the White House the
State Department the vice president's
office despite denials in the past it's
going to be difficult to counter this
now the reason the White House had been
confident up to this point is they felt
that they had gotten something very
positive from the hearings on Tuesday
afternoon kurt volker for example that
was mentioned throughout this test and
when he had essentially done something
positive for the president said there
there was no quid pro quo so now we've
got these two statements that directly
contradict one another it's going to be
up to the Republicans now moving forward
to try and dissect that but given the
fact that we have new details from
Gordon Sandlin given the fact that he is
a Republican donor to President Trump
it's going to be very difficult to
accomplish that task okay Kimberly
halket following all this from the White
House Kimberly thank you we'll get back
to you let's bring Steve Clemens into
the conversation the host of the bottom
line al Jazeera's weekly political show
he joins us live from Washington DC I'm
Steve this feels like an inflection
point today it's a huge earthquake
you know the hearing in part began with
the ranking member of the Intelligence
Committee Devin unis warning ambassador
Sunland that that the Democrats were
going to smear his reputation that
didn't happen and now you wonder what's
have this was Gordon Sandlin moving and
shifting just like kurt volker
ambassador Volcker shifted yesterday
these were two moves I think the
Republicans did not expect and you do
feel as if the you know the
teeter-totter has now gone the other
direction and so I think this is
staggeringly important I think his
testimony was electric and powerful and
blunt and on the issue of the ecosystem
around the president and what everyone
thought was essentially a quid pro quo
we now don't have any ambiguity as as
far as this testimony is concerned so
when you talk about the president's
ecosystem yes Gordon saw Allen said
everyone was in the
lü about what was going on he also does
that this phrase is interesting it was a
continuum of insidiousness he said that
back in May it started with these
generic requests on behalf of President
perhaps through Rudy Giuliani too for
there to be some sort of investigations
into corruption generally speaking and
then he says it became more and more
clear that this was specifically about
getting the president of Ukraine to make
an announcement
not necessarily the investigation but an
announcement of an investigation into
burry smih and into the Biden so he said
it became more and more clear and then
he says eventually he started to realize
that the release of the eight the four
hundred million dollars was contingent
upon upon all of this happening and he
made it clear that so many people knew
about this what what does this say how
much bigger is this Steve if everything
that I just said is something that the
president's chief of staff was aware of
the Secretary of State was aware of
Secretary of Energy was aware of the
former national security adviser was
aware of what does it say that
potentially all of these people knew
this was happening with Richard Nixon
they're some of the movies and books
that followed that by Woodward and
Bernstein were called all the
president's men in this case I think you
could call all the president's people
essentially around him were either
trying to enact what the president
wanted which was this quid pro quo a
deal with zalenski that he would make a
public announcement of of this
investigation into the Biden's and
Purisima and then the aide would be
released or there were members in the
administration like john bolton like
fiona hill like Colonel vid Minh and
others that were blowing the whistle and
saying this was wrong inappropriate all
of these people were not Democrats
challenging Donald Trump there is a
divide that's very interesting between
those who thought they were just
carrying out the president's orders and
those inside who said this is
inappropriate behavior but they all
belong to the president's team and that
is what we're seeing play out today and
I think that's what's so interesting
and will be interesting to see how the
Republicans defend this because in the
past in the testimony that we heard the
other day from ambassador Taylor and and
Deputy Assistant Secretary Kent you had
a case where there they were being
challenged that maybe they didn't hear
or see what they thought they did now
that has been removed and I think what
it says to your question is it means
that we've got a validity a solvency to
these claims that the president wanted
this and it's going to be very very hard
I think for the Republicans to dispute
that and I think we're now will you know
probably see an evolution in this
discussion - okay maybe the President
did want that it's still not impeachable
but I see